this disaster remains an emergency and
even now it's growing in different ways
on Grand Bahama and oil storage facility
next to pristine waters is spewing oil
into the environment the hurricane winds
literally tore off the lids of these
huge tanks oil is clearly using out of
one of the stores the land around the
facility is saturated in oil one of the
tanks appears to have emptied itself
with so much damage to the islands
infrastructure and so much human need
nobody's been able to deal with this yet
and the human crisis remains a serious
problem roads and bridges linking
isolated communities are still
unpassable on Abaco island the community
of Fox Town is only just getting aid the
houses here were overwhelmed by the
storm surge people are still waiting in
lines hoping to be evacuated it's
happening but the process is long and
there are so many others in need as well
while they may have made it on board
this is another family split by this
storm and thousands upon thousands of
people here are homeless many has still
not been able to get to safely
this village wants home to 2,000 people
doesn't have a name now it doesn't exist
either completely leveled by durian but
as we circled we saw signs of life
washing on clotheslines
attendant glimpse of people beneath us
we landed it took them what food and
water we had and to see how they were
these are the Haitian workers of a long
since closed farm they took us into what
was the center of the village how anyone
survived here is quite remarkable it has
been obliterated most of the survivors
fled in the aftermath of the storm
leaving this small group behind they're
cut off they have no communication or
vehicles nobody knew they were here
forgotten in the chaos so people came
out of the house
yeah to try to forget to another house
and then it got blown down too but the
storm lasted a long long time you come
back come back come back
Natha what happened here was horrendous
the emotional toll it's taken on the
survivors is difficult to imagine
everything for them must seem hopeless
now however strong they appear they're
hurting
none of these survivors have been able
to speak to their family since the storm
they used our satellite phones in the
first contact is hard to the roof of
mark Sam Vincent's home was torn off in
seconds have you put this back on so the
whole roof so under the car here and and
you survived in there yeah holding his
wife and baby they made it outside and
hid beneath the car incredibly they
survived what happens next
he has no idea get my wife on NASA
yesterday yeah how families have been
torn apart by Hurricane Dorian none will
ever forget this but perhaps the
youngest of the most resilient
meaning and water whoo you scared yes
sir this battered group in this
destroyed community is representative of
so many thousands of people who endured
the storm and are now struggling with
the survival like the islands themselves
the people will take years to recover
steer MC Sky News in the Bahamas